how's it going with my name's Perry pack
I got something cool to show you both
today I got a pair of racer hydrous they
are kind of like two remotes a lot of
games oculus rift games are optimized
with them because you can like move your
hands in the game which is really cool
we're gonna do starting simulated with
these and yeah let's see how it works
out all right so here we are if you have
been you know it clap your hands come
here a chop what am I
this is gonna be so messy yeah okay
before do we have too much fun this is
gonna be [ __ ] great let me touch your
titties Bob I can't wait to touch them
mmm eh feels so soft and nice but what
the hell is this Bob he's saying your
beautiful breasts ah god damn it Ike I
bought these just so I can touch some
kiddies some virtual titty like a that
[ __ ] Bobby well maybe we can find the
tennis somewhere else
that's what my momma always said if you
can't find titties you've gotta you got
to go deeper okay
here's that [ __ ] here's bris pierce
brosnan get that away get that away get
that away that we went through his body
yes throw it in his face god damn it
oh well close enough hey high five Bob
don't worry I'll go find myself I can't
do it I cannot do it
nah oh god damn it I'll find your
[ __ ] face
yeah Bob don't worry you're in safe
hands
- you can bet that come on ah yes yes
give me that [ __ ] give me that Oh III
take it you bet up get that shut down
away from me
don't make me slap you Bob if you don't
cooperate I'll slap the [ __ ] out of you
[ __ ] gameplay of a Call of Duty go [ __ ]
yourself
slap Bob I just need the syringe ah son
of a [ __ ] it's your fault Bob it's all
your fault
I've never give me too much fun with
this Oh dad
taste my ass you [ __ ]
that's not my ass oh okay okay don't
panic there we go I'd stuck alright
catch Bob
oh you suck at catch catch this [ __ ] and
yes oh I can't believe I did it I'm a
[ __ ] genius
[ __ ] go away from me I am as [ __ ]
professional okay there you go
just grab it and slammed on come on is
right there yeah
d alright press a lot of fun these are
if you have em you know it touch my face
a little only hope you boys enjoy
watching leave a like if you did and
subscribe to become a red today and I'll
see in the next one Sandra's my beeper
oh wait you know what I'm gonna brofist
bomb bomb yeah bro fast
brofist myself
okay this is how we end this video
profit yeah bro fisting yourself